c'est sur ce matelas posé parmi les
déchets que d'arras mais depuis quelques
jours c'est loin des conditions de vie
dont il rêvait en rejoignant ceuta
depuis le maroc à la nage lundi dernier
le dos relais la grande majorité des
quelque huit mille migrants des
marocains surtout ont été renvoyés dans
leur pays par les autorités espagnoles
mais art med espère arriver à fuir les
policiers pour rejoindre le continent
européen abdullah à 14 ans il est arrivé
ici avec ses compagnons de jeu après
avoir entendu sur les réseaux sociaux
que la frontière était ouverte
il dit avoir frappé aux portes des
centres d'hébergement ouverts dans des
entrepôts désaffectés des gymnases à
ceuta les avec plus de 800 enfants
hébergés ils affichent complet ils sont
encore nombreux ces jeunes mineurs à
traîner dans les parcs et autour des
centres commerciaux à s'accrocher comme
yacine 16 ans à cet idéal d'une vie où
ils seraient respectés considérés en
syrie
les problèmes de migration illégale ne
sont pas nouveaux à ceuta la ville
espagnol enclavé sur les côtes
marocaines de la méditerranée est une
cible de choix pour ceux qui ne voient
d'autre avenir qu'un avenir européen
mais jamais ceuta n'avait connu un tel
raz-de-marée la population ici est
composé à 50 % de chrétiens et 50 % de
musulmans
la crise actuelle tire très fort sur les
fils qui retiennent le tissu social
selon le vice-président de la ville qui
parle d'une invasion sur la stratégie
vers la pression migratoire importante
la pression on est dans une tranquillité
pour la faune père est là combien fils
afida est difficile reconnaît la casse
par un équilibre fragile et des tensions
ravivées par la venue du chef de vox un
parti d'extrême droite
il avait annoncé un rassemblement de ses
partisans au centre ville en justice
citant des raisons de sécurité a fait
interdire la manifestation mais le
dirigeant politique s'est entêté c'est
donc à coups d'insultés comme raciste
fasciste provocateur et quelques
obscénités qui se passe de traduction
que santiago abascal a été accueilli par
ces contre manifestants tribunal n'aura
pas fait changer d'avis le dirigeant du
parti got ici pour une deuxième fois en
une semaine à peine
la colère de ces manifestants elle aura
finalement eu raison de ses plans
c'est plutôt à l'intérieur de son hôtel
protéger de la colère des manifestants
par un cordon policier que santiago
abascal fera une déclaration à la presse
les photos pour ceux qui sont venus
c'est un drame humain qui se joue bien
loin des crises politiques
un espoir dérobé pour plusieurs une
déception amère pour d'autres qui
n'attendent plus qu'on leur montre la
porte ils repartent comme ils sont venus
mais beaucoup retenteront leur chance
sur ces quelques centaines de mètres qui
les séparent de leurs aspirations
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada à
ceuta en espagne